The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu
PROFESSOR: Review what
random processes are
a little bit now.
And remember, in what we're
doing here, we have pointed
out that random processes
in general, have a mean.
The mean is not important.
The mean is not important for
random variables or random
vectors either.
It's just something you add
on when you're all done.
So the best way to study random
variables, random
vectors, and random processes,
particularly when you're
dealing with things which are
based on base things being
Gaussian, is to forget about the
means, do everything you
want to with the fluctuations,
and then put the means in when
you're all done.
Which is why the notes do most
of what they do, in terms of
zero mean, random variables,
random vectors, and random
processes, and simply put in
what the value of the mean is
at the end.
OK so some of this has
the mean put in.
Some of it doesn't.
So to start out with, a random
process is defined by its
joint distribution at each
finite set of epochs.
OK, that's where we started
with all of this.
How do you define a
random waveform?
I mean, you really have to
come to grips with that
question before you
can see how you
might answer the question.
If you think it's obvious how
to define a random process,
then you really have to go
back and think about it.
Because a random process
is a random waveform.
It's an uncountably infinite
number of random variables.
So that defining what it is,
is not a trivial problem.
And people have generally agreed
that the way to define
it, be the test for whether you
have defined it or not, is
whether you can find the joint
distribution at each finite
set of epochs.
Fortunately most processes of
interest can be defined in a
much, much simpler
way in terms of
an orthonormal expansion.
When you to find it in terms of
an orthonormal expansion,
you have the orthonormal
expansion which is the sum
over k, of a set of random
variables, Z sub 1, Z sub 2
and so forth Z sub k, times a
set of orthonormal functions.
So all the variation on t
is stuck into the set of
orthonormal functions.
All the randomness
is stuck into the
sequence of random variables.
So at this point, you have a
sequence of random variables,
rather than a waveform.
Why is it so important to have
something countable instead of
something uncountable?
I mean, mathematicians
understand, in a deep
mathematical sense, why
that's so important.
For engineers the argument is
a little bit different.
I think for engineers the
argument is, no matter how
small the interval of a waveform
you're looking at,
even if you shrink it, no matter
what you do with it,
you can't approximate it in any
way and get rid of that
uncountably infinite number
of random variables.
As soon as you represent it
in terms of an orthonormal
expansion though, at that point
you have represented it
as a countable sum.
As soon as you represent it as
a countable sum, you can
approximate it by knocking
off the tail of that sum.
OK, and at that point you have
a finite number of random
variables, instead
of an infinite
number of random variables.
We all know how to deal
with a finite
set of random variables.
You've been doing that since
you were in 6.041 OK.
So if you have a countable set
of random variables, the way
to deal with them is
always the same.
It's to hope that they're
defined in such a way that
when you look at enough of them,
all the rest of them are
unimportant.
That sort of is the underlying
meaning of
what countable means.
You can arrange them
in a sequence, yes.
But like when you count in
school, after you name the
first hundred numbers you get
tired of it, and you realize
that you understand the whole
thing at that point.
OK in other words, you don't
have to count up to infinity
to understand what it
means to have a
countable set of integers.
You all understand
the integers.
You understand them
intuitively.
And you understand that no
matter how big an integer you
choose, somebody else can always
choose one bigger than
you've chosen.
But you also understand that
that's not important.
OK?
So this is the way we usually
define a stochastic process, a
random process to
start off with.
The other thing that we have
to do, is given a random
process like this, we very often
want to go from this
random process to other random
processes which are defined in
terms of this random process.
So almost always we start out
with a random process which is
defined this way.
And then we move from there to
various other processes which
we define in terms of this.
So we never really have to deal
with this uncountably
infinite number of
random variables.
If we really had to
deal with that, we
would be in deep trouble.
Because the only way we could
deal with it, would be to take
five courses in measure
theory.
And after you take five courses
in measure theory,
it's not enough.
Because at that point, you're
living in measure theory.
And most of the mathematicians
that I know can't come back
from measure theory to talk
about real problems.
So that every time they write
a paper, which looks like
beautiful mathematics, it's very
difficult to interpret
whether it means anything
about real problems.
Because that's where
things get hard.
OK so the point is, if you
define random processes in
this way, then you always have
some sort of grounding about
what you're talking about.
Because you have a countable
number of
random variables here.
You know that if you're dealing
with anything that
makes any sense, only a
finite number of them
are going to be important.
The thing you don't know is how
many of them you need to
be important.
OK, so that's why we take
an infinite sum here.
Because you don't know ahead of
time, how many you'd need
to deal with.
OK, so we then started to
talk about stationarity.
The process Z of t is stationary
if Z of t sub 1 up
to Z of t sub k and Z of t sub
1 plus tau up to Z of t sub k
plus tau have the same
distribution.
OK, so you take any finite set
of random variables in this
process, you shift them all to
some other place, and you ask
whether they have the
same distribution.
How do you answer
that question?
God only knows.
I mean, what you need to be able
to answer that question
is some easy way of finding
those joint probabilities.
And that's why you deal
with examples.
That's why we deal with jointly
Gaussian random variables.
Because once we're dealing with
jointly Gaussian random
variables, we can write down
those joint distributions just
in terms of covariance
matrices.
Well it means, of course, if you
want to deal with things
that are not a zero mean.
And after you learn how to deal
with covariance matrices,
at least you're dealing
with a function of a
finite number of variables.
So it's not so bad.
OK so the argument is, this is
what you need to know if
you're going to call
it stationary.
But we have easier ways
of testing for that.
And in fact this Wide Sense
Stationary we said, if the
covariance matrix, mainly the
expected value of Z of t sub 1
times the expected value of Z
of t sub 2 is equal to some
function of just t sub
1 minus t sub 2.
In other words, where the
expected value of this value
times this value is the
same, if you shift it
over by some amount.
OK, you see the difference
between?
I mean the difference between
these two things is one, that
in the definition for
stationarity, you need an
arbitrarily large set of
random variables here.
You shift them over to some
other point here.
And you need the same joint
distribution over this
arbitrarily large set
of random variables.
When you get into dealing with
the covariance matrix, all you
need for Wide Sense Stationarity
is you only have
to deal with two random
variables here, and the shift
of those two random
variables here.
Which really comes out to a
problem involving just two
random variables t sub 1, t sub
2, and the fact that it's
the same no matter where you
shift the t sub 1 to.
It's only a function of the
difference between t
sub 1 and t sub 2.
So it's a whole lot easier.
And then we pointed out that
since jointly Gaussian random
variables, and since the
Gaussian random process, it's
completely determined by its
covariance function, a zero
mean Gaussian process.
If you'll forgive me, I'm not
going to keep coming back and
saying that.
I will just be thinking
solely today in terms
of zero mean processes.
And you should think solely in
terms of zero mean processes.
You can sort out for yourselves
whether you'd need
a mean or not.
That's sort of a trivial
addition to all of this.
OK, so it's Wide Sense
Stationary.
Well we already said that.
Well, here I put in the mean.
OK, Wide Sense Stationary
implies that it's stationary
for Gaussian processes.
OK, so in other words, this
messy looking question of
asking whether a process is
stationary or not, with all of
these random variables here
and all of these random
variables here, becomes
trivialized for the case of a
Gaussian random process, where
all you need to worry about is
the covariance function.
Because that's the thing that
specifies the whole process.
OK.
That's part of what
we did last time.
We set an important
example of this.
And you don't quite know how
important this is yet.
But this is really important
because all of the Gaussian
processes you want to talk about
can be formed in terms
of this process.
So it's nice in that way.
And the process is Z
of t is the sum of
an orthonormal expansion.
But the orthonormal functions
now are just the time shifted
sinc functions.
We know the time shifted sinc
functions are orthogonal.
So we just have this set
of random variables.
And we say OK, what we're going
to assume here is that
these random variables, well
here I put in the mean.
Let's forget about the mean.
The expected value of V sub k
times V sub i, namely any two
of these random variables
expected value of the pair, is
equal to zero if K
is unequal to i.
OK, in other words, the random
variables are in some sense
orthogonal to each other.
But let's save the word
orthogonal for functions, and
use the word correlated
or uncorrelated
here for random variables.
So these random variables
are uncorrelated.
So we're dealing with an
expansion where the functions
are orthogonal, and where
the random variables are
uncorrelated.
And now, what we're really
interested in, is making these
random variables Gaussian.
And then we have a Gaussian
random process with
this whole sum here.
We're interested in making these
have the same variance
in all cases.
And therefore what we have is
process which is stationary.
And its covariance function is
just sigma squared times this
sinc function here.
There's an error in the notes,
in lecture 16, about this.
It will be corrected
on the web.
This is in the notes.
This quantity here
is left out.
So you can put that back
in if you want to.
Or you can get the new notes
off the web after a
few hours or so.
This is not put on
the web yet.
I just noticed yesterday.
In fact I noticed
it this morning.
OK, the sample functions of a
Wide Sense Stationary non-zero
process are not L sub 2.
When I talk about a non-zero
process I'm not talking about
zero mean, I'm saying this
peculiar random process which
is zero everywhere.
In other words, a random process
which really doesn't
deserve to be called
a random process.
But unfortunately by
the definitions,
it is a random process.
Because with probability one,
Z of t is equal zero
everywhere.
And that just means you have
a constant, which is zero
everywhere.
So you're not interested
in it.
OK, if you take the sample
functions of any non-trivial
Wide Sense Stationary
random process,
they dribble on forever.
And they have the same--
no matter how far
you go out in time--
the V sub k's which are the
samples of this process,
sample random variables of
the process, weigh out.
These things all have
the same variance.
So that this is stationary
because it just
keeps going on forever.
OK and as we said last time,
that runs into violent
conflict with our whole idea
here of trying to understand
what L sub 2 functions
are all about.
Because what we would like to
be able to do is stick the L
sub 2 functions as sample values
of these processes,
have the waveforms that
we send the L sub 2.
When you add up two L
sub 2 functions, you
get an L sub 2 function.
And therefore, all the sample
values of all the things that
happen with probability one
are all L sub 2 functions.
As soon as you do the most
natural and simple thing with
random processes, you wind up
with something which cannot be
L sub 2 anymore.
But it's not L sub 2 in
only a trivial way.
OK in other words, it's
not L sub 2 because
it keeps going forever.
It's not L sub 2 for the same
reason that sine x is not L
sub 2, or 1 is not L sub 2.
OK, and we've decided not to
look at those functions as
reasonable functions for
the waveforms that
we transmit or receive.
But for random processes, maybe
they're not so bad.
OK.
But we don't know yet.
We started to talk about
something called effectively
Wide Sense Stationary,
which the notes talk
about quite a bit.
Which to say, OK we will assume
that the process is
stationary over some very
wide time interval.
We don't know how wide that time
interval is, but we'll
assume that it's finite.
In other words, we're going to
take this random process,
whatever it is, you can define
it, a nice random
process this way.
And then we're going to get our
scissors, and we're going
to cut it off over here
and we're going to
cut it off over here.
So it's then, time-limited over
this very broad band.
Why do we want to do this?
Because again, it's like the
integers which are countable.
You don't know how far out you
have to go before you're not
interested in something
anymore.
But you know if you go out
far enough, you can't be
interested in it anymore.
Because otherwise you
can't take limits.
You can't do anything
interesting with sequences.
OK, so here the idea is.
If you go out far enough,
you don't care.
This has to be the way that you
model things because any
piece of equipment that you ever
design is going to start
being used at a certain time,
and it's going to stop being
used at a certain time.
And about halfway after when
it stops being used, the
people who make it will
stop supporting it.
And that's to hurry on the time
at which you have to buy
something new.
I bought a new computer
about six months ago.
And I find that Microsoft is
not supporting any of the
stuff that it loaded into this
damn computer anymore.
Six months old, so you see why
I'm angry about this matter,
of things not being supported.
So in a sense they're not
stationary after that.
So you can only ask for things
to be stationary over a period
of six months or so.
OK.
But for electronic times, when
you're sending data at
kilobits per second or megabits
per second, or
gigabits per second as people
like to do now, that's an
awful long time.
You can send an awful lot
of bits in that time.
So stationary means stationary
for a long time.
The notes do a lot of
analysis of this.
I'm going to do a little
of that analysis
here in class again.
Not because it's so important
to understand the details of
it, but to understand what it
really means to have a process
be stationary, and to understand
that doesn't really
destroy any of the L sub 2
theory that we built up.
OK.
So the covariance function
is L sub 2 in
cases of physical relevance.
That's the thing.
That's one of the
things we need.
We want the sample functions
also to be L sub 2 in cases of
physical relevance.
If you have a function here,
this is just a function of
time now at this point.
There's nothing random
about this.
It's just a statistic of
this random process.
But it's a nice well-defined
function.
We're talking about real
random processes here.
So what can you say about
this function?
Is it symmetric in time?
How many people think it
must be symmetric?
I see a number of people.
How many people think
it's not symmetric?
Well it is symmetric.
It has to be symmetric because
its expected value of Z of t
sub 1 times Z of t sub 2, and if
you flip the roles of those
two, you have to get
the same answer.
So it is symmetric.
It is real.
We're going to talk about the
Fourier transform of this
before trying to give any
relevance or physical meaning
to this thing called
spectral density.
We'll just say this is the
Fourier transform of the
covariance function for a Wide
Sense Stationary process.
So we have some kind of
Fourier transform.
We'll assume this is L
sub 2 and everything.
We won't worry about
any of that.
So there is some function
here which makes sense.
Now if k is both real and
symmetric, what can you say
about its Fourier transform?
If you have a real function,
what property does this
Fourier transform have?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's conjugate
symmetric, yes.
And furthermore, if k is
symmetric itself, then you can
go back from this thinking you
have a symmetric transform,
and realize that this
has to be real.
OK.
So spectral densities of real
processes are always both real
and symmetric.
We will define what we mean by
spectral density later for
complex processes.
And spectral densities
are always real.
They aren't always symmetric if
you have a complex process.
But don't worry about
that now.
There are enough peculiarities
that come in when we start
dealing with complex processes,
that I don't want
to worry about it at all.
So spectral density is
real and symmetric.
And so far it's just
a definition.
OK, but the thing we found about
this sinc process, is
that the sinc process in fact,
is a stationary process.
It's a Wide Sense Stationary
process for whatever variables
you want to put in here.
And if these variables are IID
and they're Gaussian and zero
mean, then this process is a
zero mean, stationary Gaussian
random process.
And it has a spectral density.
This turns out to be
a sinc function.
The Fourier transform of it
is a rectangular function.
So this process has a spectral
density which is constant out
to a certain point, and then
drops off to zero.
So it's nice in that sense.
Because you can make this be
flat as far as you want to,
and then chop it off wherever
you want to.
And we'll see that when we start
putting a process like
this through filters, very
nice things happen.
OK.
So we're familiar, relatively
familiar, and conversant with
at least one Gaussian
random process.
OK, we talked about linear
functionals last
time before the quiz.
And we said a linear functional
is a random
variable, V, which is simply
this integral here.
We've talked about this integral
a lot where Z of t is
a function, and g of
t is a function.
If the sample values of Z of
t are L sub 2, then this
integral is very well-defined.
It turns out, also, that if g
of t is L sub 2, and these
sample values are bounded, then
all of this works out
very nicely also.
And we'll find other ways to
look at this as we move on.
OK but what this means is that
for all sample points in this
entire sample space, in other
words we're dealing with a
probability space where we
have a bunch of processes
running around, we have
data coming in.
We're transmitting the data.
We have data that
gets received.
We're doing crazy
things with it.
All of this stuff is random.
We might have other processes
doing something else.
Big complicated sample space
here for all of the elements
in it, the sample value of the
random variable, V, is just
the integral of the sample value
of the process here.
In other words for
each omega, this
process is simply a waveform.
So it's this waveform times the
function g of t, which we
think of like that.
So if g of t is time limited in
L sub 2, if g of t is time
limited as far as these sample
functions are concerned, we
don't give a fig about
what Z of t is
outside of that interval.
And if we're going to only deal
with linear operations on
this process where those
linear operations are
constrained to some interval,
then we don't care what the
process does outside
of that interval.
And since we don't care what
the process does outside of
that interval, we can simply
define the process in terms of
what it's doing from some large
negative time to some
large positive time.
And that's all we care about.
And so we wanted to find
effective stationarity, as
something which obeys
the law of
stationarity over that interval.
And we don't care what it does
outside of that interval, OK?
In other words, if Microsoft
stops supporting things after
six months, we don't
care about it.
Because everything we're going
to do we're going to get done
within six months.
And if we don't get it done
within six months we're going
to have a terrible crash.
And we're going to throw
everything away
and start over again.
So it doesn't make any
difference at that point.
OK, so we have a process now
we'll assume is effectively
stationary within
two time limits.
And our definition is if the
covariance function, which is
a function of two values, t
and tau, namely it's the
expected value of Z of t times
expected value of Z of tau.
And our definition of effective
stationarity is that
this is equal to a function of
t minus tau, whenever t and
tau are in this box.
OK, and we drew figures last
time for what that meant.
We drew this box, you know,
bounded by T sub 0 over 2.
And what this effective
stationarity means, is that on
all these diagonal lines, the
covariance function is
constant on those
diagonal lines.
And that gives us the same
effect whenever we're passing
this process any time we're
calculating the inner product
of a sample value of the process
with some function,
which is contained within
those limits.
All we need to know about is
just what the process is doing
within minus T sub 0 over 2
to plus T sub 0 over 2.
Nothing else matters.
And therefore, something is
effectively stationary within
those limits means that we get
the same answer here, whether
or not it's stationary.
Why is that important?
It's important because the
things that you can do, the
simple things that you can do
with stationary processes are
so simple that you'd like to
remember them, and not
remember all these formulas
with capital T sub 0's
floating around in them.
Because having a capital T sub
0 in it is just as crazy as
assuming that it's stationary,
because you never know how
long it's going to be until
Microsoft stops
supporting its software.
I mean, if you knew
you'd never buy
their products, right?
So you can't possibly know.
So you assume it's going
to go on forever.
But then, when we try to ask
what does that mean, we say
what it really means is over
some finite limits, which are
large compared to anything we're
going to deal with that
at all of these results hold.
So eventually we're trying to
get to the point where we can
leave the T sub 0 out of it.
But we're going through this
so we can say, OK there's
nothing magical that happens in
the limit as T sub 0 goes
to infinite.
Mainly we're trying to really
derive the fact that all these
results can be established
over a
finite interval of time.
And therefore you don't care.
OK.
So if this covariance function,
single variable
covariance function, is
less than infinity,
what does that mean?
What is a single variance,
single value, covariance
function of zero mean?
It's the expected value of Z of
T, times Z of T. In other
words, it's the variance of
the process at T for any T
within minus T sub 0 to plus T
sub 0, or T sub 0 over 2 to
plus T sub 0 over 2.
OK?
So if that variance is finite,
then you can just integrate
over the sample values of
the process, and you
get something finite.
In other words this is what
you need for the sample
functions to be L sub 2
with probability one.
As soon as you have this, then
you're in business with all of
your L sub 2 theory.
And what does your L
sub 2 theory say?
It really says you can ignore
L sub 2 theory.
OK, that was the nice
thing about it.
That was why we did it.
OK in other words, the whole
thing we're doing in this
course is we're going through
complicated things sometimes
so that you can know
how far you can go
with the simple things.
And we always end up with
the simple things
when we're all done.
OK, and that's the
whole principle.
I mean we could just do the
simple things like most
courses do.
Except then, you would never
know when it applies and when
it doesn't apply.
So, OK.
So there we are.
Let's talk about linear
filtering of processes.
The notes don't do quite
enough of this.
So when I get to the place where
you need it I will-- and
some of it's on this slide--
I'll tell you.
We're taking a random process
and we're passing the sample
waveform of that random process
through a linear
filter, a linear time and
variant filter, so some other
random process comes out.
OK, and now the output at some
time tau, is just the
convolution of the input Z of t
times this filter response h
of tau minus t.
And you can interpret this
in terms of these sample
functions the way
we did before.
But now we already sort
of understand that.
So we're just interpreting in
terms of if there's a random
variable V, which is the value
of the process at time at
epoch tau, which is
given in this way.
It's a random variable when you
pass the process through
the filter.
OK, if Z of t is effectively
Wide Sense Stationary with L
sub 2 sample functions, and if h
of t is non-zero only within
finite limits, minus A to plus
A, what's going to happen?
When you pass the sample
waveforms through a linear
filter, which is bounded between
minus A and plus A,
that linear filter cannot do
anything with the inputs.
Namely the output that comes out
of there at some time, T,
can't depend on the input
anymore than A
away from that output.
OK in other words, let me
draw a picture of that.
Here's some time where we're
observing V of t.
And V of t can depend on Z of t
only in this region here, Z
of t minus A up to Z of t plus
A. OK that's what the
convolution says.
That's what those filter
equations say.
It says that this output, here
at this time, depends on the
input only over these
finite limits.
And again remember we don't care
about realizability here.
Because the timing at the
receiver is always different
from the timing at
the transmitter.
OK so what that says then
is, what does it say?
It says that we know that Z of
t is Wide Sense Stationary
over these big limits minus T
sub 0 to t sub 0 from six
months ago until six
months from now.
And this linear filter is
non-zero only over one
millisecond.
It says that the process which
comes out, is going to be Wide
Sense Stationary over minus
six months plus one
millisecond to six months
minus one millisecond.
And that's just common sense.
Because the filter isn't moving
the process any more
than that little bit.
OK.
So V of t then, is going to be
Wide Sense Stationary in L sub
2 within those slightly
smaller limits.
The covariance function is going
to be the same thing
that it was before if you had
a completely stationary
process, if you only worry about
what's going on within
those limits, T sub 0 minus A to
T sub zero plus A. You can
take that big mess there, and
view it more simply as a
convolution.
Let's see, this part of it is a
convolution of h of t with K
tilde, which is the covariance,
which is a
function of one variable.
And then it's convolved with--
and here I put in the complex
conjugate of h, because it's
easier to do it here.
Because at some point, we want
to start dealing with complex
random processes.
And for filters it's
easy to do that.
For linear functionals
it's a little harder.
So I want to stick to
real processes.
If we're dealing with filtering,
I can simply define
this covariance function as the
expected value of Z of t
times Z complex conjugate
of tau.
And when you do that, we're
taking this integral, which is
the convolution of h
of t with K tilde.
And then we're convolving
it with h complex
conjugate of minus t.
Because the t gets turned
around in there.
And what that says when you take
the Fourier transform of
it, at least what
I hope it says--
I'm not very good at taking
Fourier transforms.
And you people, some of you
are very good at it.
We get the spectral density of
the process, Z of t times the
magnitude of h hat of f.
Now this is the formula, which
is not in the notes
I just found out.
And it's a very important
formula.
So you ought to write it down.
It says what the spectral
density is on the output of
the filter, if you know the
spectral density of the input
of the filter.
And it's a kind of a neat,
simple formula for it.
It says, you pass a
random process.
I mean, it's like the formula
that you have when you take a
waveform and you pass it through
a linear filter.
And you know it's kind of easier
to look at that in the
frequency domain where you
multiply, than it is to look
at it in a time domain where
you have to convolve.
Here things become even simpler
because all we have to
do is take the spectral density,
which is now a
function of frequency, multiply
it by this magnitude
squared, and suddenly
we get the spectral
density at the output.
Now what happens when you take
this nice sinc filter, this
sinc Gaussian process that we
have, which is flat over as
large a bandwidth as you
want to make it.
And you pass that process
through a linear filter.
What do you get out?
You get a process out which has
any spectral density that
you want within those
wide limits.
OK, so just by understanding the
sinc Gaussian process and
by understanding this result,
you can create a process which
has any old spectral density
that you want.
And if you can create any old
spectral density that you
want, you know you can create
any old covariance function
that you want.
And all of this is good for
Wide Sense Stationarity so
long as your filter doesn't
extend for too far.
Which says all of our theory
works starting at some
negative time going to some
positive time, taking filters
that only exist for a relatively
small time.
If it's Wide Sense Stationary
and it's Gaussian, then
everything works beautifully.
You can simply create
any old spectral
density that you want.
If you have some waveform that's
coming in, you can
filter it and make the output
process look whatever you want
to make it look like, so
long as you have the
stationarity property.
Now you know the secret of
why everybody deals with
stationary processes.
It's because of this formula.
It's an incredibly
simple formula.
simple idea.
You see now we know
something else.
We know that it also applies
over finite,
but large time intervals.
OK.
So just to spell out the
conclusions once more, a Wide
Sense Stationary process
is Wide Sense
Stationary after filtering.
So if you start out with Wide
Sense Stationary, it's Wide
Sense Stationary when
you get done.
If it's effectively Wide Sense
Stationary, it's effectively
stationary with a reduced
interval of effective
stationarity after you filter.
OK in other words, if you start
out with a process which
is effectively stationary from
minus T sub 0 to plus T sub 0,
then after you filter it with
any filter whose impulse
response is limited in time,
you get something which is
effectively stationary within
that six months minus one
millisecond period of time.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: Don't you
differentiate [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Effectively Wide
Sense Stationary, thank you.
I try to differentiate between
them, but sometimes I'm
thinking about Gaussian
processes, where it doesn't
make any difference.
Is effectively Wide Sense
Stationary with reduced
interval after filtering.
OK, good.
The internal covariance, in
other words, the covariance
function within these intervals,
the spectral
density, and the joint
probability density aren't
affected by this interval of
effective stationarity.
In other words, so long as you
stay in this region of
interest, you don't care
what T sub 0 is.
And since you don't care
what T sub 0 is, you
forget about it.
And for now on we will
But we know that whatever
we're dealing with, it's
effectively stationary within
some time period, which is
what makes the functions
L sub 2.
We don't care how big that is.
So we don't have to
specify T sub 0.
We don't have to
worry about it.
We just assume it's big
enough and move on.
And then if it turns out it's
not big enough, if your system
crashes when one of Microsoft's
infernal errors
come up, then you worry
about it then.
But you don't worry about
it before that.
OK so now we can really define
white noise and understand
what white noise is.
White noise is noise that is
effectively Wide Sense
Stationary over a large enough
interval to include all time
intervals of interest.
Also on the other part of
white noise, is that the
spectral density is constant
in f over all
frequencies of interest.
OK in other words, white noise,
really you have to
define it within terms of what
you're interested in.
And that's important
to understand.
If you're dealing with wireless
channels, you
sometimes want to assume that
the noise you're seeing is
actually white noise.
But sometimes you do things
like jumping from one
frequency band to another
frequency band to transmit.
And when you jump from one
frequency band to another
frequency band, the noise
might in fact be quite
different in this band, than
it is in this band.
But you're going to stay
in these bands for a
relatively long time.
So as far as any kind of
analysis goes which is dealing
with those intervals, you
want to assume that
the noise is white.
As far as any overall analysis
that looks at all of the
intervals at the same time, in
other words, which is dealing
with some very long-term
phenomenon, you can't assume
that the noise is white.
OK in other words, white noise
is a modeling tool.
It's not something that occurs
in the real world.
But it's a simple
modeling tool.
Because what do you
do with it?
You start out by assuming
that the noise is white.
And then you start to get some
understanding of what the
problem is about.
And after you understand what
the problem is about, you come
back and say, is it really
important for me that the
noise is going to have a
constant spectral density over
this interval of interest?
And at that point you
say, yes or no.
OK.
It's important to always be
aware that this doesn't apply
for times and frequencies
outside
the interval of interest.
And if the process is also
Gaussian, it's called white
Gaussian noise.
So white Gaussian noise is
noise which has a flat
spectral density over this
effective stationarity period
that we're interested in, over
some very large period of
time, minus T sub 0
to plus T sub 0.
And over some very large
frequency interval, minus W up
to plus W or even better over
some limited frequency band in
positive and negative
frequencies, the spectral
density is constant.
You can't define the spectral
density until after you look
at this effective period
of stationarity.
But at that point, you can
then define the spectral
density and see whether it looks
constant over the period
you're interested in.
You can either see whether it
is, or if you're an academic
and you write papers, you
assume that it is.
OK.
The nice thing about being an
academic is you can assume
whatever you want to assume.
OK let's go back to linear
functionals.
The stuff about linear
functionals is
in fact in the notes.
This will start to give us an
idea of what spectral density
really means.
So if I have a Wide Sense
Stationary process, a linear
functional, well this
is what a linear
functional is in general.
But for a Wide Sense Stationary
process, we have
the single variance, single
variable covariance function.
The expected value of the
product of two random
variables of this sort is
just this integral here.
This is what we did before.
If you don't remember
this formula, good.
It's just what you get when you
take the definition of V
sub i, which is the integral of
g sub i of t with Z of t.
And then you multiply
it by V sub j.
And you take Z of
t and Z of tau.
And you take the expected
value of the two.
And then you integrate
the whole thing.
And it sort of comes out to be
that, if I've done it right.
You can express this in this
terms, namely as the integral
of g sub i of t times a
convolution of this function
times this function.
You can then use Parseval's
identity.
Because this convolution gives
you a function of t, OK.
When you integrate this over
tau, this whole thing is just
a function of t.
OK.
So what we're dealing with is
the integral of a function of
t times a function of t.
And Parseval's relation says
that the integral of a
function of time, times a
function of time is equal to
the integral of the
Fourier transform
times the Fourier transform.
OK.
You all know this.
This is almost the same as a
trick we used with linear
filters, just slightly
different.
So that says that this expected
value is equal to
this product here.
And here I've used the complex
conjugate for the Fourier
transform of g sub j, because I
really need it there if g is
not a symmetric function.
OK so if these Fourier
transforms, g sub i of t and g
sub j of t are non-overlapping
in frequency, what does this
integral go to?
And this is absolutely wild.
I mean if this doesn't surprise
you, you really ought
to go back and think
about what it is
that's going on here.
Because it's very astonishing.
It's saying that stationarity
says something you would never
guess in a million years
that it says.
OK it says, that if this and
this do not overlap in
frequency, this integral is 0.
OK in other words, if you take
a linear functional over one
band of frequencies, it is
uncorrelated with every random
variable that you can take in
any other band of frequencies.
So long as the function is Wide
Sense Stationary, this
uncorrelated effect
takes place.
If you're dealing with the
Gaussian random process, it's
also stationery.
Uncorrelated means
independent.
And what happens then, is that
expected value of V sub i and
V sub j is zero.
V sub i and V sub j are
statistically independent
random variables.
And it says that whatever is
happening in one frequency
band of a stationary Gaussian
process is completely
independent of what's happening
in any other band.
Now if any of you can give me
an intuitive reason for why
that is, I would love
to hear it.
Because I mean it's
one of those--
well after you think about it
for a long time, it starts to
sort of make sense.
If you read the appendix in the
notes, the appendix in the
notes sort of interprets
it a little bit more.
If you take this process, if you
limit it in time and you
expand it in a Fourier series,
what's going to happen to
those coefficients in
the Fourier series?
If the process is stationary,
each one of them, if you think
of them as being complex
coefficients, the phase in
each one has to be random and
uniformly distributed between
zero and 2 Pi.
In other words, if you have a
phase on any sinusoid, which
is either deterministic or
anything other than uniform,
then that little slice of the
process cannot be Wide Sense
Stationary.
And there's nothing in any other
frequencies that can
happen to make the process
stationary again.
OK in other words, when you
expand it in a Fourier series,
you have to get coefficients
at every little frequency
slice, which have uniform
face to them.
In other words, the Gaussian
random variables that you're
looking at, are things that
are called proper complex
Gaussian random variables which
have the same variance
for the real part as for
the imaginary part.
When you look at them
as a probability
density, you find circles.
In other words, you find
circularly symmetric random
variables at every little
frequency interval.
And that's somehow, what
stationarity is
implying for us.
So it's a pretty important
thing.
And it doesn't just apply
to white noise.
It applies to any old process
with any old spectral density,
so long as we've assumed that
it's Wide Sense Stationary.
OK.
So, different frequency bands
are uncorrelated for Gaussian
Wide Sense Stationary
processes.
Different frequency bands
are completely
independent of each other.
OK, as soon as you have
stationary noise, looking at
one frequency band to try to get
any idea of what's going
on in another frequency band,
is an absolute loser.
You can't tell anything from one
band about what's going on
in another band.
So long as you're only looking
at Gaussian noise If you're
sending data which is correlated
between the two
bands, then of course
it's worthwhile to
look at both bands.
But if you're sending data
that's limited to one
frequency band, then at that
point, there's no reason to
look anywhere else.
We're going to find
that out when we
start studying detection.
It'll be a major feature of
understanding detection at
that point.
OK, and one of the things you
want to understand with
detection, is what things can
you ignore and what things
can't you ignore.
And this is telling us something
that can be ignored.
It's also starting to
tell us what this
spectral density means.
But I'll interpret that in
the next slide I hope.
OK if you take this set of
functions g sub j of t, in the
notes I now convert that set
of functions to V sub j's
instead of g sub j's.
If I start out with that set
of functions these--
oh dear, this is a
random variable--
V sub j is the component of the
process in the expansion,
in that orthonormal set.
So in other words, you can take
this process, you can
expand it into an orthonormal
expansion using random
variables and these orthonormal
functions.
If g sub j of t is a narrow
band, and S sub Z of f is
constant within that band-- in
other words we don't need
white noise here.
All we need is a spectral
density
which changes smoothly.
And if it changes smoothly,
we can look at a
small enough interval.
And then what happens?
When we take the expected value
of V sub j squared, what
we get is this times
this times this--
OK the product of these three
terms and since this--
that's supposed to
be a j there.
OK so what's happening is these
are narrow band, this is
just a constant within
that narrow band.
So we can pull this out and
then all we have is the
integral g sub i of f times g
sub i complex conjugate of f,
which since these functions are
orthonormal, is just one.
So what we find is that random
variable there is simply the
value of the spectral density.
Now we don't use that to figure
out what these random
variables are all about.
We use this to understand
what the spectral
density is all about.
Because the spectral density
is really the energy per
degree of freedom in the
process at frequency f.
In other words, if we use
orthonormal functions which
are tightly constrained in
frequency, they just pick out
the value of the spectral
density at that frequency.
S sub Z of f sub 0 is just sort
of a central frequency in
this band, or integrating
over here, OK.
So the interpretation of the
spectral density is that it's
the energy per degree of
freedom in any kind of
orthonormal expansion you want
to use, so long as those
functions are tightly limited
in frequency.
So that's what spectral
density means.
It tells you how much energy
there is in the noise, at all
these different frequencies.
It tells you, for example at
this point, that if you start
out with a sinc Gaussian process
like we were talking
about before, pass it through
a filter, what the filter is
going to do is change the
spectral density at all the
different frequencies.
And the interpretation of that
which now makes perfect sense
when you're going through a
filter, is the amount of
energy in each of those
frequency bands is going to be
changed exactly by the amount
that you filtered it.
OK so we have a nice
thing there.
S sub Z of f is the energy per
degree of freedom in the
process at frequency f.
For a Gaussian Wide Sense
Stationary process, this is
the energy per degree
of freedom at f.
And the noise at all different
frequencies is independent.
That's what we were
saying before.
And after filtering, this
independence is maintained.
In other words, you pass a
Gaussian random process
through a filter and you still
have independence between all
the different frequency bands.
It's an absolutely remarkable
property.
Just this property of the
process acting the same at
each time as it acts at each
other time, that this leads to
this amazing property of things
being independent from
one frequency to another is
really worth thinking about.
And it's one of the things
that people use when they
actually design systems.
I mean it's almost natural
to use if you
don't think about it.
If you start thinking about it
then it becomes even more
worthwhile.
OK should I start detection?
Let me just start to say a few
things about detection, then I
want to stop in time to
pass the quiz back.
OK let's talk about where
detection fits in with our
master plan of what
we've been doing.
We started the course talking
about what was over on this
side of the channel business,
namely all the source coding
and all of those things.
We then started to talk about
how do you do signal encoding.
In other words, how do you map
from binary digits coming in,
into signals.
Well we never talked
about this problem.
We only talked about this
problem, when you
didn't have any noise.
We carefully avoided dealing
with this problem at all.
Then we talked about
baseband modulation
for PAM and for QAM.
For PAM it was real, for
QAM it was complex.
Then we talked about how you go
from baseband frequencies
up to passband frequencies.
Now we've been talking about
what happens when you add
white Gaussian noise, or any
other noise at passband.
Then you go from passband
down to baseband.
When I do this, we're going to
have to come back at some
point and deal with the question
of what happens when
you take passband white Gaussian
noise and convert it
down to baseband.
Because some kind of funny
things happen there.
And we have to deal with it
with a little bit of care.
But let's forget about that
for the time being, and
suppose everything works
out all right.
Then we go through our
baseband demodulator.
Finally something comes out of
the baseband demodulator,
which we hope is the same
as what came out
of the signal encoder.
But what we're trying to do at
this point now, is when the
noise is here to say, this is
in some sense, going to be
what we put in plus noise.
And for the time being, in terms
of looking at detection,
we will just assume that.
We will assume that this thing
down here is what went in,
plus noise.
And assume that all this process
of passing white
Gaussian noise through this junk
gives us just a signal
plus noise.
OK, so what a detector does is
it observes a sample value of
this random variable V, or it
observes a vector, or observes
a random process.
It observes whatever it's
going to observe.
And it guesses the value of
another random variable.
And we'll call the other random
variable H. We had been
calling it other things
for the input.
It's nice to call it H because
statisticians always call this
a hypothesis.
And I think it's easier to think
of what's going on if
you think of it as a
hypothesis type random variable.
Namely the detector
has to guess.
If we have a binary
input, it has to
guess at a binary output.
It has to flip a coin somehow
and say, I think that what
came in is a zero, or I think
what came in is a one.
The synonyms for detection are
hypothesis testing, decision
making, and decoding.
They all mean exactly
the same thing.
There's no difference whatsoever
between them,
except the fields that they
happen to deal with.
And each field talks about
it in a different sense.
The word detection really came
mostly from the radar field
where people were trying to
determine whether a target was
there or not.
And hypothesis testing
has been around for
a great deal longer.
Because all scientists from time
immemorial have had to
deal with the question of have
you collect a bunch of data
about something.
And it's always noisy data.
There's always a bunch of
junk that comes into it.
And you have to try to make some
conclusions out of that.
And making conclusions out of
it is easier if you know
there's only a finite
set of alternatives
which might be true.
In a presidential election,
after you know who the
candidates are, it's
a binary decision.
The people who try to guess who
people are going to vote
for, are really doing binary
decision making.
They don't have very good
probability models.
And it certainly isn't
a stationary process.
But in fact, it is a detection
problem, the same as the
detection problem
we have here.
So all these problems really
fall into the same category.
We're fortunate here at having
one of the cleanest
probabilistic descriptions
for detection that
you will ever find.
So if you want to study decision
making, you're far
better off trying to learn about
it in this context and
then using it in all these other
contexts, than you are
doing something else.
If you go back and look at old
books about this, you will be
amazed at the philosophical
discussions that people would
go through about what makes
sense for hypothesis testing,
and what doesn't make sense.
And all of these arguments were
based on a fundamental
misapprehension that scientists
had until
relatively recently.
And the misapprehension that
they had, was that they
refused to accept models as
taking an intermediate
position between physical
reality, and then you have
models, and then you have doing
something with a model.
And you do something with the
model instead of doing
something with the
physical reality.
And people didn't understand
that originally.
So they got the analysis of the
model terribly confused
with trying to understand what
the physical reality was.
In other words, statisticians
and probabilists were both
doing the same thing.
Both of them were trying to
simultaneously determine what
a reasonable model was,
and to determine what
to do with a model.
And because of that, they can
never decide on anything.
Because they can never do what
we've been doing, which says
take a toy model, analyze
the toy model.
Figure out something from it
about the physical reality.
Then go back and look at reality
and see what you need
to know about reality in order
to make these decisions, which
is the way people do
it now I think.
Particularly decision theory
is done that way now.
Because now we usually assume
both that we know Apriori
probabilities, it's called,
for these inputs here.
For the binary communication
problem, we usually want to
assume that these inputs are
equiprobable, in other words,
if P sub 0 is equal to
a half, and P sub 1
is equal to a half.
And that's the Apriori
probability of
what's coming in.
And we then want to assume some
probabilistic model on v.
Usually what we do, is we figure
out what v is in terms
of a conditional probability
density, conditional
probability density of v,
conditional on either of these
two outputs.
You see for this model here,
this is just made
in heaven for us.
Because this thing is
an input plus a
Gaussian random variable.
So if we look at the conditional
probability
density of the output, which
is signal plus noise,
conditional on the signal is
just a Gaussian random
variable shifted over
by the input.
OK.
So we have these two
probabilities, the input
probability, this thing, which
statisticians call a
likelihood, which is the
probability of this
conditional on this.
And in terms of that, we try
to make the right decision.
Now, I think I'm going to stop
now so we can pass back the
quizzes and so on.
Before Wednesday, if you don't
read the notes before
Wednesday, spend a little bit of
time thinking about how you
want to make the optimal
decision for this problem as
we've laid it out now.
What's surprising is that it
really is a trivial problem.
Or you can read the notes and
accept the fact that it's a
trivial problem.
But there's nothing
hard about it.
The only interesting things in
detection theory are finding
easy ways to actually solve
this problem which is
conceptional trivial.
OK.